they were looking for a win having lost
three straight this is West group a both
teams playing in their first group play
match Anthony Davis back in the lineup
that's big time Kevin Durant Bradley
Beal stepping up for the Suns and it's
be getting it going early man that
that's a great sign from the Phoenix
Suns to him moving that way and being
able to dunk it they can get him in all
three healthy well we look out speaking
of look out yeah that's scary LeBron
sliding with his left leg into Kevin
Durant Durant he'd make one of two free
throws would stay in the one
three it looks so easy I mean
automatic
LeBron would miss the free throw and
wincing in
pain
[Music]
o red across the eye yep oh no he didn't
Bradley Beal no no you
didn't Bradley be with 24 points in this
game no Deon Booker no timeable on his
return Phoenix was up 6355 at the break
LeBron three ball was working clicking
tonight man shooting the ball with
confidence how about KD he's been doing
that his whole life shooting the ball
with confidence 38 points9 rebounds five
assists Phoenix up by
nine cam reddish cam reddish though
getting the start in this
game and it was a great call by Darin
ham Austin Reeves okay part of an 110
run Lakers taking the
lead then it's a king
driving Lakers up by
six man that's tough right there that's
left hand is
alive reddish making up for that last
game in Miami where he misses the three
similar play LeBron hits him again
reddish makes it and it's the Lakers
going on to win this one 122 119
snapping their three-game losing Street
getting a win in group play LeBron James
leading away 32 Points 11 rebounds six
assists here he is post game cam reddish
got the start tonight what did he show
you uh nothing I've already known this
in Cam and uh to all the uh naysayers
and basketball Savant that don't know
nothing about basketball and telling me
I should have shot that shot in Miami
instead of passing to cam reddish well I
did the same thing tonight because I
trust my teammates and I make the right
play every single time and uh game ball
go to cam reddish for
sure so LeBron propping up his teammates
including cam Rish who had again great
game 17 points for him uh five of eight
from three getting that start and it was
the right call by Darvin ham it is I
mean cam r as we know if he get his shot
and his confidence down because
defensively he's really good and I think
for him is he just need that confidence
and LeBron James is doing that in that
interview and he he has the talent in
high school I kept saying this kid got a
chance to be really really good lost his
confidence a little bit but I think he's
finding it right now 3D yeah LeBron I'll
agree with you at the end you're always
making the right play you just like you
made the right play in Miami you made
the right play tonight but I'll disagree
that Cam's in this situation because to
Smitty's point he had lost his
confidence he was not making shots like
this consistently so now he's making
those shots cuz LeBron's a great leader
LeBron's always going to make the right
play I think that's what he was getting
to Smitty yeah for sure and we watching
this guy 21 seasons of breakdown of
LeBron looking like he's like 21 which
is scary uh they have a chance if they
can get it going Anthony Davis could
just stay healthy we get a chance to see
because we don't want to lose this
greatness when we seeing a guy at this
age 21 seasons in this game a big game
you come up with those type of points 24
11 and six four turnovers and I think he
played in every minute of foot yeah you
can forget about that minutes
restriction thing I mean play another 36
minutes tonight uh can't be on minute
restriction I was talking to coach H
about that in Miami night said I can't
we're already depleted new guys are hurt
but LeBron 11 of 17 so efficient just
playing within the game not forcing
things taking what the defense gives you
all those type of things like to say and
down the stretch he took over the ball
game and still made the right plays and
lak Nation like we stole a big game
against the Suns knowing that Kevin
Durant had a pretty good good ball game
tonight de de no Devin Booker but
Bradley Bill played pretty well yeah and
I love 3D is I haven't seen too many
walk up three-pointers like LeBron hit
tonight three ball was working his
confidence his confident in that shot
was there tonight yeah no doubt about
that